hello and welcome to see you playing
Frankie J from the US some other name
ranks of the rings a bell but you don't
know don't know what Bell exactly I mean
I need to tidy up stuff yet too many too
many windows open it always irritates me
okay I don't know what's what's the deal
against this move I think they go here
but I'm not totally sure the night h4
something like that yeah the night h5
line against this is something we're
absolutely yeah should check out the
current state of theory because I am I
don't know it well this for example
doesn't look particularly great for
white I think I feel like this is a deja
vu some kind of like I had this before
in a game and it it wasn't good in that
came and anyway at least I was
reasonably quick here
a black is ok yeah absolutely my pieces
don't make that much sense IAM okay
aggressive and probably good okay I'll
take it and now hmm yeah what to do here
g-form that that could easily backfire
but mm hey export will you see what else
okay maybe it's not so bad I can I go
Quincy tool castling long night back to
our three years old it shouldn't be
terribly bad
hmm yeah well it looked like my position
but maybe it's okay it really feels like
I had exactly that before he takes a
long time probably not a bad idea to do
that preventing you form preparing to
Castle long f3 I can just take I think
there is no big no trickery
you
okay I'm bringing this back you can take
play your forward it opens up the long
diagonal as well so not sure that this
is helping him and if I get in Bishop
reform I am ok then I believe I by the
way after you for I can castle long if
you take that this g 5y g5 immediately
but then and then you will take it to
with check this I'm not sure about 84
you cannot play this g g5 is this term
this is too too much of an issue and
that means I get in there should be four
almost but i can cancel nome e for
that's g5 so II 4G five community group
g1 wins the Queen okay so luckily one
Bishop you force around the corner or
g5g five but first of all let's get keep
this covered
your age floor next yeah somehow I got
control back in this position so what do
i do eh five to prevent the bishop move
maybe it's not an ideal I can do this
though it looks good potentially Queen
here an age six and g6 mmmm that's very
good
it looks like a winning mansion there's
a yeah age six and g6 is going to be
going to be game over I guess yeah I
don't know I didn't like the position
out of the opening it really feels like
that exactly the same opening before in
a game again this felt pretty pretty
yeah forced almost after I had this with
Bishop h6 in the first place this 123
and the computer wants to go back this
is probably a good idea probably would
have played Quincy three anyway this is
the engine suggestion playing you for
next yeah black is definitely okay I
mean my whole setup is far too strange
to be a advantageous the capture ever
i'm not sure about i still think you
should play 94-95 stuff like that check
I mean here I think I'm better because
he cannot do this because of g5 this
means the Queen watch at your book and
now I'm I'm retaining full control over
the board with G and H porn pushing up
yeah yeah here means something like this
let's same he will not survive and he
had no time on the clock yeah that
wasn't a probably that great opening
result but it didn't seem to be so bad
that I'm immediately losing or anything
like that um they have to have to study
the slide better that that immediate 89
age 59 okay thanks for watching